hello lovely people it is Wednesday and
I don't know if you've noticed but we've
been trying out a few different changes
for GameSpot news or including this guy
our fancy new thumbnail and a few other
things but at the end of the day we make
this show for you so please let us know
what you like what you don't like and
some third thing that completes the
comedy rule of threes will both be in
the comments so just swing by and have a
chat anyway for now let's talk about the
knees first up let's talk about getting
you some free game he's a free code for
guacamelee on Steam what no and I'm
telling them about the games with gold
for gene
oh yeah look I misunderstood yeah that's
my bad all right all right
in June Xbox one owners with the gold
subscription will be able to pick up a
newcomer racing game speed runners as
well as watchdogs that game you
pre-loaded and then plays an hour of I'm
pretty sure that was just you was it
anyway if you don't own an Xbox one
there's no need to worry as you can pick
up burnout paradise on Origin using this
code dan stop Microsoft already has the
free games you've wildly misunderstood
what we're doing here yeah sorry about
that
that's my bad okay just just something
happen again hey one good one Xbox 360
Ernest can get assassin's creed 3 for
the first half of the month and Dragon
Age Origins from June 16 to 30 those two
are also playable on Xbox one through
backwards compatibility a bonus offer is
no what I thought you're gonna interrupt
there huh no I got it I got it a bonus
alpha is also arriving in the form of
multiplayer DLC for the recently
released phantom dust re-release before
the month is out be sure to grab a Mays
free titles also all this Sims 3 stuff
sorry sorry that's my bad you know down
I'm a big fan of art classical modern
yes hi lucky for you far cry 5 is
amalgamated by genres in their cover art
cool alright let's have a look as you
can see the new cover art takes
inspiration from the famous Leonardo da
Vinci painting the Last Supper and I
assume duck dynasty it also appears to
keep the Far Cry style of showing the
main villain on the cover there's not
much else to go on for now but it's
probably safe to assume there will be
wolves
seaplanes and after play luckily you
don't have to speculate much longer as
Ubisoft will be showing off far cry 5
this Friday May 26th we'll be bringing
you all the details as they happen
make sure you subscribe so you can find
out just how much apple pie factors into
the story
finally rockstars parent company takes
here is that a few different things to
say about the delay of Red Dead
Redemption too if you miss that spot of
news Rockstar Games announced earlier
this week that it had delayed the game
from full 2017 to spring 2018 in order
to produce a better product tag 2 CEO
Straus Zelnick has said the delay wasn't
a result of any particular issues he
just wanted the team to have more time
to realize their vision for the game
zelich added that it's an extraordinary
understatement to say that take 2 is
highly confident in Red Dead Redemption
twos ability to appeal to a wide
audience so it's safe to say that the no
man's sky a Skype train is well and
truly rolling Zelnick added that for a
title like this he doesn't think the
launch window matters all that much as
consumers are consuming entertainment
year-round now saying we believe that if
you give people an extraordinary
experience they're going to show up for
it so many games so little time that's
GameSpot news for today I'm Dan I'm Jeff
we'll be in the comments so please come
by and have a chat and we will see you
guys tomorrow yeah